[Music]
well welcome everybody thanks for coming
out to hear our talk rajesh and i are
going to be sharing some experiences
with you i realized i'm trying to
condense about 18 months of migration
work in a lifetime of monitoring
experience into about 40 minutes but
bear with us as we try to run through
this and hopefully there'll be some time
for questions so just to kick it off my
name is troy komen run infrastructure
engineering at planet some of the
coolest work I've ever done and some of
the least interesting work at Planet
which I'll talk a little bit more about
the cool stuff that we do but my
background has been sort of an
infrastructure and clouds for quite some
time
and as for planet we are actually
imaging that the earth on a daily basis
so our first mission as a company has
been to be able to capture the landmass
of the earth every day which amounts to
about a million and a half 29 megapixel
images covering about 350 million square
kilometres that's over 6 terabytes of
data every day forever that we have to
manage and you know the other
interesting thing is that most people
want to look at pictures of the earth
that don't have clouds so I have a
really different cloud problem than
you've heard about for most of the
people here but you know we'll dive into
that a little bit as we go through this
so hi everyone
my name is Rajesh I'm the chief
architect at signal effects I joined
signal effects a little bit over five
years ago now I joined as part of the
founding team and I've been over there
working mostly on our streaming
analytics engine which we all get to
know a little bit about going forward
prior to signal effects I was at
Facebook for about four years working on
you know cluster management and
monitoring related projects and prior to
Facebook I was at Google for several
years again working on like classroom
management type software so a little bit
about signal effects so signal effects
is a monitoring and operational
intelligence solution we help people
understand their cloud environments we
take data from these
environments be there you know from
infrastructure or from application from
other services that you might be using
bring that data into signal effects and
processes it at very very low latency
real-time analytics and anomaly
detection people to really get insight
into what's happening in their in their
system and we are very pleased to have
have Planet as one of our customers
since 2017 and you know we are very
happy to share the story that we are
going to have now with Troy so what are
we going to talk about today is about
planet primarily you know all the cool
problems that they solve all the
infrastructure that they use the
problems that they face in trying to
solve these complicated image processing
and how they and how and when they
manage to kind of do their migration
from their legacy and environment into
GCP I'll chip in a little bit about
things to think about when you're
planning a migration such as this what
kind of monitoring and observability you
need to have in place to have you a
successful migration and then to
continue to operate your environment
successfully post migration so Troy you
want to take it away so just to give you
some context as I mentioned before our
kind of initial mission in the world was
to try to capture the at the earth every
day and make that accessible to as many
people as we possibly could and we're
now kind of moving we've we've
accomplished that first mission we're
getting the daily imagery of the planet
but now we're kind of moving up the
stack and realizing that what people
want is actually data and information
not just pictures and so they don't
actually want a picture of every spot on
the earth every day they want to know
you know where their buildings where
their roads when things are changing
when disasters have struck and so
increasingly we're starting to build an
analytics layer on top of our data
engine and feeding that into our
customers so our platform or the the
stack you know when we talk about full
stack it goes all the way from embedded
computers that are flying 500 kilometers
above the earth so we build and run
around ground stations we obviously have
to store and manage and process tens of
terabytes of data every single day and
then of ovid that all feeds back through
our user system we do that mostly on the
Google cloud today it starts out with
about a hundred and fifty operational
satellites the
largest operational constellation in the
world we have a fake over a dozen maybe
maybe close to 20 ground stations around
the world that received the data we
upload that into the end of the cloud we
have tens of thousands of VMs that sit
in Google cloud that crunch on that data
and then an API and sort of series of
ways for people to access that
information to kind of dive down a
little bit more from the software
perspective this data comes into our
processing engine so this is all the
stuff that kind of happens now in GCP
but you'll hear me talk a little bit
about our data pipeline which is where
we started and that really is about
getting our imagery and doing all the
work that has to be done to make that
usable by customers for example when you
take an image of the earth you've got a
2d image of what's fundamentally a 3d
surface and we have to take and
essentially map every pixel that we take
from space on to a physical location on
the earth because we want accuracy
within three meters so we have to know
for you know you can have a slightly off
telemetry in space that can cause you to
be 50 to 100 miles off of where you
thought you were of the earth so there's
a whole set of processing that has to go
to make that useful to our customers and
then it turns out everybody wants it in
different format people want web tiles
people want analytic products people
want beautiful images that look good
that are maybe stitched together of
mosaics of lots of different images
together and so all that sort of number
crunching goes on the background of our
platform so we do this you know I think
we have somewhere between 50 and 100
software engineers spread around the
company and we're located our
headquarters is here in San Francisco we
have a large office in Mountain View but
we also have offices in Canada Texas
Berlin and remote employees sort of
spread worldwide so it's a very
distributed environment our development
work is mostly in Python historically we
were doing a lot more with go with new
pieces and then a lot of our front-end
work is JavaScript based we are entirely
cloud based we have almost no on Prem
hardware and what I'm going to talk to
you about is a lot of our stuff started
in AWS we still have some things there
some things will always remain there
because of regulatory requirements that
we need gov cloud but we about 18 months
ago began a process
of migrating to Google and I'm just
gonna tell you a little bit of the
things we learned during that during
that process so a timeline you know I
realized we already have one
inconsistency in our slides we we sort
of talked about integrating with signal
effects in 2016 and you said 2017 but
we've been with signal effects sort of
embedded in our infrastructure very
early and the big thing for us is really
this this marketing point of launching
our 80 satellites our first production
set of satellites in January of 2017 and
we knew that we needed art cloud we our
cloud choice was going to become kind of
permanent around that time frame because
once we started actually downloading a
million and a half pictures a day we
were going to move a lot and as it was
we had a lot of data to move so we kind
of began our evaluation process around
here we started our first phase
migration in December and then actually
flipped live before the last next
conference in San Francisco which was
actually in March of 2017 and then we
can we've kind of kept our phase 2
migration going over the last 18 months
or so since then and I'll walk you
through some of our experiences but this
gives you a general idea of the flow so
why did we end up on Google after we did
our analysis there were a couple
different things first of all we really
felt there was a good product fit a lot
of the network and storage capacity
pieces lined up with a lot of the data
requirements that we had we particularly
liked the ability to use predictable VMs
our preemptable VMs which have
predictable pricing versus things like
spot markets on AWS where the market
fluctuations were difficult for us to
manage with the pricing model felt very
natural for sort of how where we came
from this sort of bursty you know images
sort of flow in and out we're bursting
up and down and it flowed well for that
and we also have there are a lot of if
you've been around the conference there
have been other geospatial data
providers talking but there's a
community of geospatial data providers
there's a lot of you know new geospatial
features coming out in bigquery and
other platforms and it just felt like a
good fit from a market fit
we also interestingly enough acquired
Terra Bella which was the T in the
alphabet product line of Google their
satellite business is actually
in part of planet NOW and so we have
other strategic relationships that have
made sense for us and we also I guess
the last thing I would say is their
commitment to open source technologies
particularly kubernetes and some other
things lined up well with how we wanted
to to grow and do things at planet so we
did a two-phase migration at planet we
because all of those satellites were
going up and we were going to start
getting rained down with sat at in in 20
last year we made a decision to get that
moved as quickly as possible I was
looking at one of the the slides
beforehand where I was talking about
Evernote moving 3.5 petabytes of data
over a seven day period we moved seven
and a half petabytes in under 30 days
which was which I'll talk a little bit
about some learnings from that but that
was a was a big chunk of the move but we
also ended up moving about 40,000
servers worth of work from one cloud to
the other in that same sort of 70 to 90
day window and so I'll talk a little bit
about kind of the things we learned and
where we end up we took the rest of our
we had have a lot of merging
applications that were more
customer-facing and less heavily
trafficked and we actually did some work
to kind of refactor those move them into
containers and kubernetes and and
migrate them to Google later some things
worked good about that some things not
quite so good and I'll talk about some
of the trade-offs there but that process
is actually still ongoing and it's kind
of dragged out as we needed it to over
the course the last period of time so in
that first you know if you look at our I
guess our overall environment today some
key tools that we use for automation and
tooling we tie into github and get lab
we use their their automation
environment were heavily bet on sort of
containers as a mechanism for deploying
apps Jenkins and ansible probably other
two kind of heavy automation tools then
we have our pipeline we're not very
imaginative at naming things so we have
a company name planet' we have an
application name storage we have another
application name jobs and I'll talk
about those and then we kind of have our
API services platform that's kubernetes
based that has moved
since then so I talked about a few of
these pieces but I think you know what I
want to say is that the automation that
we had invested in made the migration
much easier and we intentionally decided
not to change a lot of that when we move
to Google so obviously we had to do some
things where we had to take ansible
abstractions for AWS and substitute them
with ansible extractions for Google we
you know had to go do a few even commits
to upstream you know I think I did a
commit to Packer to support some
advanced Google cloud features because
we are crazy people that like to use
stuff in alpha on Google cloud and which
I'll tell a story about that later but
you know so we but those open-source
tools were there and we leverage them
heavily to get to move move forward on
the platform as we went and it really
served as a pretty strong foundation for
making the migration go relatively
quickly so the phase one piece was the
storage and an imagery platform and so
we moved storage over it it consists
largely of all the imagery is stored in
GCS just as images so we don't do any
special sort of database for those
images we store the blobs in GCS the the
sort of secret sauce I guess comes into
play with how we manage all the metadata
so we keep track of which satellite it
came from where we took the picture
what rectification coefficients we need
what color curves we've applied to the
image all that type of data over the
history of the lifetime we keep and that
used to be stored in a Postgres database
primarily because of post J's was as the
geospatial information extensions to
Postgres and so we moved a 20 terabyte I
think a 10 or 20 terabyte Postgres
database over in the process since we've
been on Google that we then migrated a
lot of that metadata out of Postgres
into BigTable but we did that as a
two-step process that worked very well
for us and I'll talk about that our jobs
platform really is just a batch queueing
platform that manages a pool of VMs and
I'll give you an idea of what that pool
looks like and how we scaled that over
time and then phase 2 which is what
we're in the middle of now is really all
of our container based services so we
moved all of these public facing API
into containers onto kubernetes
self-hosted kubernetes on AWS and then
what we've done is built a
similar platform on Google and then
allowed people to basically repoint
their deployments from a kubernetes
environment at AWS to a kubernetes
environment in Google we also make heavy
use of cloud sequel mostly Postgres and
well we have a lot of elasticsearch in
here but I don't want to talk about that
because anybody that does operations
probably doesn't like to talk about
elasticsearch I'll answer questions if
you want but we do have a couple of very
large elasticsearch backends for all of
this as well so with that in mind of
kind of the background of what we did
I'm gonna let Rajesh talk a bit about
some of the monitoring ideas that I
think we both have a philosophy for but
he has way more experience with Thank
You Troy so I'd like to talk a little
bit about how you go about monitoring
something as complicated as migrating
from one environment to another but the
first thing I want to raise is that when
you're considering such a large change
you should really think strategically
about monitoring so obviously making a
change in cloud environments is a big
change but if you think about it over
the lifecycle of your entire service or
your entire product you know that's only
one of the changes that your system has
to be able to handle you'll obviously be
making changes to various kinds of
implementations various kinds of
architectures new builds even things
like configuration changes and these are
all things that you'll have to kind of
be able to monitor over the lifecycle of
your service monitoring is not only
about observing system behavior but also
understanding it do you really want to
have insight into what's happening
inside your service not just seeing that
it's okay it's processing some number of
transactions but what's it doing under
the covers so that you know if something
goes wrong what's actually happening
under the hood and so when you're doing
something as complicated as migrating
from one environment to another you want
to ensure that you have the right
monitoring strategy way before you
actually start doing the migration so
you saw that planet actually started
using you know signal effects a couple
of years before they actually finish
their their migration and and the reason
you want to do this is you want to move
as few things you want to change as few
things as possible when you actually do
this migration you want to establish all
the baselines and have all the
observability that you need way before
you actually execute the migration and
it's a good opportunity to use your
coming GCP migration as a forcing
function to ensure that you're kind of
putting all the right monitoring best
practices in your organization the right
philosophy of observability and having
the right to Ling and the right the
right products in place for you to
ensure that you understand what your
system is actually doing so the
first-class observability once you have
it is not only going to help you manage
this migration but it'll help you
operate your service after you complete
the migration so a few lessons too to
share about monitoring in general so
there's much more to monitoring than
just infrastructure especially when
you're moving from one cloud system to
another so for one thing like system
metrics are not very useful they are
often not even comparable across
different cloud environments because for
example what's an instance type in AWS
might not map exactly to what you have
in GCP and so you it doesn't really make
sense to compare things that aren't
really comparable it's like apples and
oranges but there are some more like
systemic problems with with using just
system metrics so oftentimes system
metrics do not indicate application
performance issues
you know your Lord Lord a virgin's might
look fine your memory utilization might
look fine but your application might
actually be struggling for various other
reasons and even when system metrics do
indicate system performance issues they
often are not very actionable in the
sense they don't tell you what the
problem is they just tell you that there
is a problem so you really need to go
beyond system metrics you want to take
what we call a data driven approach to
development and operations the key
insight here is that you cannot
understand you cannot improve you cannot
manage what you don't measure so you
really need to think about measuring all
the things that matter to you as a
person who is developing an application
what you characterizes proper behavior
of that application even if you have a
really simple service for example it
might be some kind of a lookup service
you get a request to look up something
you look it up in the cache if it's
there in the cache you can return it if
it's not in the cache you put it into a
queue and maybe there's a thread pool
that pulls stuff off the queue looks it
up in a database and then returns it
well you should be measuring not only
the number of requests that you're
getting but you should be measuring the
number of cache hits
of cache misses what's the size of your
queue what's the size of your thread
pool what's the utilization on this
thread pool each of these
instrumentation points is hardly like
one or two lines of code but believe me
it'll pay off in spades when something
falls in the pot so if you are in doubt
instrument okay so that the wrong time
to wish you had instrumentation is like
when you are in the middle of an outage
it's 3:00 a.m. in the morning and you
wish that you knew what was actually
happening over there you see that things
are running slow but you don't know if
it's the database or if it's the cache
or what what is the problem right there
so a well a fairly moderately
instrumented application you know of
moderate complexity it's it's not
unusual for them to even send thousands
of metrics poor hosts it's not unusual
but once you do that if you have let's
say a thousand metrics coming per host
and you have thousands or tens of
thousands of instances you are now
looking at millions of time-series and
you can't it really absorb that kind of
information so you really need to use
then analytics to boil all this
information down into a small number of
KPIs that you can actually absorb so
obviously you know you need to be
measuring the KPIs which are the you
what you promise as a service to your
clients so these are the SLA s the SLO s
the SLI is that the clients of your
service care about you obviously need to
be measuring that because otherwise you
cannot guarantee that you're actually
meeting any of those objectives but
equally you should also be measuring the
things that you as an application writer
care about right you should be for
example if it was that lookup service I
would want to know what's the hit ratio
what's the aggregate he should hit ratio
across the entirety or what's the 99th
percentile of the of the queue sizes
across my entire tier what's the what's
the thread utilization on my thread
pools so there are some small number of
metrics that will carry you know kind of
capture what the what's happening in
your system if you think about a pilot
who is flying a complicated airplane
there's obviously a lot of metrics that
available to that pilot right there
everything from like various hydraulic
treasurer's and oil pressures and oil
temperatures and exhaust gas
temperatures and all that stuff but
that's not what's on the pilots HUD the
pilot is operating the system based on a
small number of metrics that are
projected onto the head-up display and
yes if something happens then yes they
are available to you those are the
metrics are available
to to debug and fix the problem and you
need to take that same sort of mentality
when you are operating your own
applications so use analytics to take
all this complicated into information
and boil them down to the small number
of metrics that you're actually
monitoring now second use your
monitoring tools to establish a baseline
for system behavior so this is one of
the reasons why you want to set up your
monitoring and observability tool chain
where before you actually do the
migration what is normal for your system
it's not always a very simple question
to answer so here's a here's a chart of
activity in one of signal affected zone
systems and you can see that it's very
strongly periodic this is activity over
a week so you can see that in the
weekdays there's a lot of activity on
the system during the weekends it's not
so active and so somebody came up to me
and asked hey Rajesh is 30000 normal
well 30000 is not normal if it's Sunday
afternoon it's also not normal if it's
Monday noon but it is about normal if
it's if it's Monday at 9:00 a.m. so what
is normal would depend a lot on your
systems like this system is of course
very dependent on on weekly behavior but
you can imagine other systems that
behave for example there might be a
warm-up phase when you push a service
that your cash is or get cold and so it
takes some time for your caches to warm
up and that might be normal for your
system there might be other things where
it's very periodic but on a monthly
basis or on a quarterly basis or based
on other business activity that might
happen in your system so you want to
make sure that you're capturing all
these metrics and you have enough
baseline in them that when you do your
migration you have something to compare
it with if you don't have given if
you've not given yourself enough time to
establish that baseline you're not going
to be able to again compare and know
that if you're migrated instances are
kind of doing something that is normal
now of course comparing it to past
behavior is one notion of what's normal
you might also want to compare it to
your other control groups so if you're
migrating from from let's say AWS to GCP
and you have some instances running and
GCP you want to measure apples to apples
comparison of what is happening on GCP
versus what's happening on AWS and again
here you don't want to be doing the
system metrics you want to be doing the
KPIs and the other metrics that really
give you a proper comparison if your
system is working well now this whole a
versus B is not just like GCP versus AWS
right it
me or here is my canary build or here is
an alternate implementation of an
algorithm which i think is going to be
much better well is it better you should
be measuring it that's the only way
you're going to know if you actually
made an improvement or not and not just
measuring it in a synthetic benchmark
you want to be testing it in production
to make sure that it's working as you
intended to work in this case we
actually pushed out a canary build and
you can see that the canary build is
working very very different than the
rest of the population of the server's
in this case it was actually an
optimization so doing what as it was
intended if it was not we would have
caught it within a few seconds or
minutes and reverted the canary so the
third thing is that timeliness of
metrics and analytics is critical okay
so micro-services you know data sampling
frequency there's a lot that can happen
within the span of a few minutes like
most of you are familiar with all these
like micro service architecture these
are very large complicated dynamic
systems they are growing and shrinking
they get auto provisioning they are auto
scaling they are doing a lot of stuff
and a lot can happen within a span of a
few minutes so you may fail to identify
patterns and activity by sampling kind
of like coarse-grained metrics or things
that are very very high latency
just imagine the computer to continue
kind of like the aviation metaphor
imagine a pilot trying to fly an
airplane where all the instruments
updated once a minute instead of every
time they made a change to the controls
but that's what most people are trying
to do nowadays they are trying to
operate these very very large
complicated systems by looking at
metrics that operate like once a minute
so lay low latency real-time monitoring
really really lets you understand how
the system behaves when you make changes
to them when you push a canary when you
update a configuration how does your
system really behave to be able to
identify the patterns that happen and to
be able to react very quickly when
something is happening that you don't
expect or something that you don't
understand or something that should not
be happening to be able to identify
those behaviors it reacted them remedy
the problem and verify that your that
your remediations are actually working
so you know the way I like to think
about it is that your your system is
telling a very complicated story and you
should be watching the movie in not a
slideshow
so this is the value of real-time
streaming analytics in terms of having
ingesting high-resolution low latency
data and giving you analytic insight
instantaneously
so to summarize make sure that you go
beyond infrastructure level metrics
measure all the things that matter to
your system and if you are in doubt
measure it's always easy to throw data
out if you don't need it but it's
impossible to you can wish as much as
you want you're not going to get the
instrumentation in when you need it when
things are falling in the pot use
analytics because at this point you're
gonna have a whole lot of data you
really need analytics to help you
identify aggregate system behavior
identify outliers deviations from normal
behavior and establish that baselines
for for system behavior and and measure
in measure in real time in just at the
highest possible resolution with the
lowest possible latency for you to kind
of operate your system successfully so
try is now going to talk us through how
planet labs did their migration so just
to kind of touch on some of the metrics
that we've used first of all I apologize
a lot of the migration we did predated
the year back I can look in the graphs
that we have so most of the graphs are
not right during the middle of the
migration but I found some that I think
show a lot of the kinds of things that
we found her in the migration and sort
of how we think about it so I'll dive
into a few of these more directly so
this is kind of just to give you an idea
of the environment that we were working
in during the migration period so this
goes back to July 2017 in December of
2016 when we started our migration we
had everything running on AWS
we were processing about 300,000 images
a day we had never run more than 20,000
of our worker VMs in the history of the
company and in fact a couple years
before that we hadn't run more than
about 500 of them so we had been on this
ramp for a while and in the middle of
this ramp right when we launched all of
our big satellites we moved to Google
and this is kind of what happened next
is we went really quickly through this
period so I talked about how we launched
a bunch of satellites in January it
actually takes us a while to
operationalize those satellites so those
satellites didn't really start coming
online until June and July but you'll
see this big shift in our work
as we as we sort of went through a whole
set of things around that period and
then you know we've kept going over time
as we've launched more satellites and
gotten more products we actually hit a
new new record of 53,000 concurrent vm's
running just a few weeks ago and so this
is just kind of a good graph to remind
us kind of where we've been and what
we've been up to and sort of the scale
that we've been able to get on the
Google cloud here's another example of
where we track API response time so this
is a similar you know this is an
application level metric not really a
system level metric but we're tracking
just response times and capabilities so
this was actually a new endpoint in our
storage system that we have been
developing for some new capabilities
that our developers wanted to use and
we're tracking it sort of over history
but you'll see that when you know we can
tell when we flip the switch when that
started to go you'll see we found a
problem somewhere along the way where we
got huge spikes that we caught pretty
quickly and then we're able to correct
and sort of monitor so just another
example of one of the kind of small
things that we watch on our Ops teams
this one I think is just a good way of
how you can sort of watch changes
through the system and I do wish we
could sort of stretch this back to the
migration timeframe but this is sort of
looking at some metrics of our back-end
database server for that storage
environment that I talked about so this
is an environment that's tracking over 2
billion objects and all the metadata
that's associated with that so we we
moved it to Google and learned some good
lessons about moving big databases that
I'll get to later but one of the big
things that we wanted to do was actually
leverage BigTable to manage a lot of our
metadata so we had all this stuff stored
in Postgres in a horribly inefficient
manner like just big JSON blobs and set
up a Postgres column if you want to have
fun sometime have hundred K JSON blobs
and Postgres columns and try to manage
that so we pulled all that data out and
put it into BigTable and flip the switch
on that an environment and again to
track sort of what we wanted our network
utilization the day we flip the BigTable
switch just dropped because all that
data stopped coming out of our system
and started coming out of BigTable
instead so this was just like one of
those metrics that we could sort of see
what was happening during that time
frame another thing that we did is we
went we used to have an on base an on
disk based backup where we would run
peaty dumped to get our backups I think
PG based back up to our pieces but we
switched over to actually mounting a
persistent extra persistent disk and
snapshot in the database to persistent
disk and then moving that persistent
disk and you'll see that that new backup
popped in and in our disk activity so
this is actually the the instance where
we do all of our backups and so we were
getting lots of disk activity until we
did the snapshot stuff and that sort of
dropped off and then I guess the last
thing that sort of shows here is we
actually one of the things about
Postgres is if you drop a big table or a
column in our case that was this all
this JSON data the storage for that
doesn't go away immediately you actually
have to dump and restore the database to
get it to get it away so that the
performance came down in the network
bandwidth but that was all the disk East
utilization was still there in the
system so we decided we would build a
brand new go from a 9-3 server to a 9-5
server do a dump and import of the
database and as things sort of happened
this was the first try it didn't work
which is kind of why we see some spikes
and everything goes back to normal but
we figured out why it didn't work and a
few months later pulled the trigger
again and sort of got to got to watch we
see a new database server but we were
able to do it before and after
comparison to the old to the new to make
sure that the statistics lined up and
certainly didn't get any worse than it
did before so I think it just sort of
you know this is obviously over a very
long period of time so it's not what we
use operationally but it's great to tell
the story or maybe this is our version
of the movie of what happens to big
Postgres database as a planet is very
useful for us another big thing that we
get out of our environment that we love
is the fact that we are our AWS platform
our monitoring and visibility looks
exactly like our GCP so I mentioned that
we're moving these kubernetes
environments back and forth so we use an
internal tooling system called k2 to
deploy kubernetes into AWS and that k2
platform we named all of again we're
really good at naming we named all of
our clusters KK something in Google we
moved to tariffs using terraform to
deploy all of our stuff we actually got
kind of creative we call that tool
teraflop which is a little more
interesting than terraform but it's all
TFK so you'll see up here we get a
common view
of both and you know our Google clusters
right next to our AWS clusters is we're
sort of walking through this environment
and that goes even deeper this is an
example of our dashboard for one of our
clusters so this is a Google cluster
these are the variety of metrics that
our standard ops guys use but this looks
exactly the same for our AWS clusters as
it does for our Google clusters so if we
get a page in the middle of the night
and we don't get those but I hear people
do when they wake up at 3:00 a.m.
they're not having to go like Oh which
environment I am and what what signals
am I looking for they see a lot of
consistency I will say the one
difference if I showed you the snapshot
is those two top lines would be blank an
AWS because we've moved to a service
mesh link or debased ingress and we
don't have that in in AWS but we've left
the format the same so that the
visibility of the Ops guys is also
consistent so with that it's kind of an
overview I thought what maybe the most
valuable thing rather than to get into
the Nitty Gritty or at least at least
maybe provide some context for the
nitty-gritty is to share with you some
things that I think we learned at planet
about doing a migration of this kind of
scale both both about how to do them and
maybe some things about Google Cloud in
the process so my number one
recommendation to anybody doing a
migration like this is don't change
anything you don't have to change you
know we well so I'll come back to that
second so I guess the first thing
actually before that times take this for
granted and I almost forgot we put this
in the slide but but the planning part
is actually essential we were in a hurry
but we took a lot of time to evaluate
the move make sure it was the right move
maybe more importantly we locked
ourselves into a conference room in San
Antonio for like a week to think of all
the things that could go wrong and how
we wanted to do this and have a lot of
debates that time upfront even though we
felt a lot of pressure to move fast was
invaluable in the process so don't
shortchange yourself on thinking about
this stuff ahead of time and asking all
the crazy questions which will never be
all the questions you will find but
you'll find that some of those were it
we're really helpful the second thing
and the one that probably rings the
truest for me because we didn't do this
everywhere is change as few things as
possible it's super tempting and
we fell into this in a couple places but
to want to fix all the problems of your
service and your app while you're
migrating you know I don't know I'm in
an old version of ansible I don't wanna
use that anymore I want to get off a
Postgres let's move to BigTable while we
move to Google that's containerize
everything will go from ansible based
VMs and AWS to containerized new
solution in GCP resist that temptation
it makes the migration way more
complicated and I guarantee you it will
take you 3 times longer to move if you
do that then if you move and then make
the change and so my recommendation is
to avoid that so we we move the biggest
part of our infrastructure probably 75%
of our servers and applications in 90
days and the last 20% that we're moving
over has taken us 18 months because it's
gotten much more predictable people are
changing lots of things the refactoring
that they want to do before they move
never quite finishes and it just sort of
drags out because it's much harder to
bracket I think things around that and
that worked for us like I think in
particular had we tried to take our 20
terabyte Postgres database and migrate
to big table while we're going to GCP
the problem is more things are going to
break and it's more confusing what broke
did it break because BigTable didn't
work for our application did it break
because the Google Cloud is different
did it break because our VPNs didn't
work like all of those things just get
more complicated so I think in some ways
it's kind of the antithesis of sort of a
micro-services or maybe a CIO sort of
incremental change approach the more you
bake into the change the more
complicated it's going to be the more
likely you're gonna fail and it's
actually going to be taking more time
another big thing you heard me sort of
talk about this and I'll get into some
details but data gravity is real it
seems like if you're looking at
migrating particularly for something
like AWS to GCP it seems like the two
most similar things on the planet are s3
and GCS so you want it's easy to just
kind of go like oh I got a bunch of data
in s3 I'm just going to copy that data
to GCSE the problem is when when you
start doing things and not everybody
does this on the scale but when you
start talking about moving seven
petabytes of data it turns out there's
there's not an O'Reilly book that is
very good about how to move seven
petabytes of data so we started
by doing some tests we you know I took a
database that was on AWS and I did a
base back up to GCP and I was totally
blown away by how fast the backup was
and thought wow this whole data copying
thing's gonna be easy the problem is one
database backup doesn't simulate moving
two billion objects from GCS that's all
and that was on one bucket I would say
and I can talk to you about why that is
but we had one bucket with a like multi
billions of objects that we were trying
to move over and so we did this testing
we thought the pipes are big because it
turns out like you know the advertisers
and the ads are all sort of going
between those two networks that both
Amazon and Google or set up to do that
but you know it turns out we use the
there's a cloud migration tool that
Google has it's actually quite good so
we just like we flip that on we pointed
at the bucket we started running our
test and we're like we're going to be
here for six months if this happens and
so we sat down with the Google team and
we figured out that you know part of it
is they're sort of serially going
through our key space object by object
doing these lookups moving this data
over and so what we ended up doing to
make a long story a little bit shorter
is that we worked with Google and how
our thing was set up and we ended up
running 32 separate simultaneous
migration jobs by dividing up the key
space we had a pretty distributed key
space we use md5 sums of all of our
images to be the main storing place so
as widely spread and we literally just
took that that key space set divided it
into the 32 groups and then put those
key spaces into 32 separate migration
jobs and flip the switch and 21 days
later seven and a half petabytes of data
was moved so you can do it but just you
have to know that it's probably you know
like what we did doesn't work for
everybody else there's different ways to
approach it I would also say probably
the other interesting story that we had
to move over was the the Postgres
database so we we have a self we have a
series of RDS databases but we also had
these larger databases that were
self-managed Postgres instances and we
thought the simple thing to do simple
thing to do would just be able to create
a read-only replica of our Postgres
database in Google so we we tried to do
that and
one of the problems that we ran into was
that we did everything inside a plan on
private networks we have regulatory
requirements and other sort of security
things that keeps everything without a
public IP so our databases in AWS had no
public IP so it's basically VPN
connected and we just couldn't get
latency throughput to keep up with our
database performance to create a replica
in GCP running across VPNs what we ended
up doing that actually worked quite well
was we took an elastic IP in in AWS
assigned it to the to the database that
we had and ran a replication across the
public network for the two or three
weeks where we were replicating into GCP
and it turns out the public network
latencies weren't as constrained as VPNs
we actually got that to work and and so
we were running for a long time with
with a replica in GCP off of our primary
database in AWS the thing that we missed
was we got so comfortable with that and
I was going to embarrass the guy on the
team who was here because he was going
to show up but he must have known I was
gonna talk about him anyway he got sick
our main DBA got sick we all took our
eyes we actually had a graph that showed
our replication stats we took our eye
off the ball we basically got everything
moved to over and ready to flip the
switch from that being the replica to
being the primary and we had had some
network latency over the weekend before
we did it that caused our other one to
get out of sync and we ended up having
to wait two extra days while the
database caught back up and we we sort
of got that solved and flipped the
switch so we kind of did part of the
part of the migration on a Friday
figured out it was going to work came
back in Monday morning that replicated
caught up we flipped it went the rest of
the way which was good because will was
onstage at next the Tuesday after that
but we got it all done on time so I just
think the whole data thing actually
turned out to be quite hard we think
about things like BigTable and these
sort of systems that are very different
but actually it's the things that look
the same that aren't quite the same that
are more the most complicated parts
about a move like this so for us I think
if you're coming from an AWS to Google
environment the biggest challenges for
us were to understand networking you
know you kind of think networking is
networking TCP is TCP but I will say
this is an area where the two
environments are probably the most diff
and I don't even you know well I don't
know my team will pick one that's better
at worse I don't even know that it's
better or worse they're just different
it's helpful to know what some of those
are probably the biggest thing for us
and this is getting better I mean I
talked a little bit about the need for
the VPNs just how to set those up like
VPNs are set up different in AWS than
they are in GCP once you've kind of
figured out how to pair them and set
them up they work very well we still do
a lot of back-and-forth we have a huge
amount of traffic going between the two
clouds over VPN and that's worked well
for us
Google's use of Sdn is really powerful
and extremely performant but causes some
things you just don't quite expect
sometimes for us it had to do with
things like first of all the internal
load balancer at Google is actually not
a load balancer like you think of it
it's not a it's not like an 88 proxy or
some kind of load balancer instance that
looks like a device it's actually
forwarding rules in the network that
just moves traffic around so they call
it a load balancer but it's really a
combination of front-end and back-end
forwarding rules in the network that
means you can't do things like terminate
SSL at the load balancer internally
because it's really just moving traffic
to your back-end devices all of which
works fine it's just different and that
was hard for us to get used to some of
the internal shared it's called Terra
PPC I keep wanting call it X PN a few
Google's will probably member it as EXPN
before it became public but the shared
PPC xpn stuff was really early for us
it's still kind of early like we didn't
know early on that you couldn't expect
to have the internal load balancer will
not work across the VPN because you know
it's just a device we know networking
devices should be available anywhere but
when you dig in you understand why that
is and we found ways to sort of work
around that and that all works very well
for us I think also private DNS was a
thing that was missing when we moved it
is being tested now we're actively
testing and hoping to move to private
zone resolution inside of Google and so
all these things I think work fine
they're just different and you need to
be aware of them you know as you're sort
of thinking through how you're going to
do things so I guess in summary for us
look our migration went really well
we're running a massive amount of stuff
in Google it's going great we're moving
new stuff over everyday we are going to
maintain a to cloud actually I guess
technically we have some stuff and
sure we'll be an AWS for our regulatory
environment that has to be in gov cloud
but we're you know and but we're also
digging in a lot mentioned heavy use of
BigTable cloud memory store a lot of the
new services that are coming out we're
strip we're trying to migrate it and
sort of embed - even as we grow we are
focused a lot on kubernetes and service
Metro proaches I will say that partly
because of this private networking
mismatch partly because of just some
experience we have in running kubernetes
we run self hosted kubernetes in google
we continue to evaluate GK as an option
but we actually have our own kubernetes
deployment that we that we run and
manage and that has worked well for us
and actually we can configure you back
on a lot of gke capabilities that have
been put into the public use for us to
do things like access underlying I am
roles in our instances and credentialing
and so forth a lot of work with the move
towards analytics to incorporate GPUs
and TP use into our infrastructure both
in the kubernetes side and in other
places and then there's just this
constant effort on our part to balance
cost and speed take advantage of
preemptable VMs you know understand what
the best patterns are for distributing
our imagery and managing egress costs
and so that's what keeps us busy going
forward now that you know we've survived
the the basis of the migration and we're
really sort of excited about that
[Music]